aux routes coupées ou encore déviation
tout au long de cet été il va falloir
vous habituer à ces panneaux dans les
yvelines
comme chaque année d'importants travaux
de sécurisation et de modernisation du
réseau vont être effectués dans 52
communes
une période qui n'est pas choisi au
hasard on peut espérer la en ce moment
c'est le cas que la météo facilite
l'organisation de ces chantiers et on le
fait aussi à une période où le flot de
circulation est moins dense
donc on pénalise moins au total 54
chantiers de différents types sont
répartis sur tout le territoire
rénovation d'un ouvrage franchissant la
scène à gargenville le pont sera coupée
à la circulation jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'août à plaisir les travaux se
poursuivent sur la passerelle au dessus
de la rd 30 au niveau du bois de la
crâne autre chantier emblématique de cet
été le giratoire de l'abreuvoir à marly
le roi on a un gros point sur lequel on
doit résoudre à la fois le problème de
la sécurité de la résistance de la
chaussée parce que les véhicules
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas les carrosses
d'antan et en même temps de faire que ce
choix joly en tous les cas que l'on
respecte cette insertion dans le shit
dans les yvelines enveloppe allouée à
l'année pour les travaux sur le réseau
routier d'environ 12 millions d'euros 70
% de ce budget consommé durant la saison
estivale